I think the number one thing is
basically to break the taboo on really
open and honest dialogue about all drug
policy options including legalization
tonight at the honor fraser gallery los
angeles drug policy alliance we've
gotten a habit of organizing these art
auctions that bring more attention to
the issue and to the organization and to
raise money we're trying to build a
national organization and national
movement to end the war on drugs in
America and really around the world the
fact that it's illegal fuels a crazy
drug policy in the crazy drug war that
we're not winning so much money goes
into trying to enforce these ridiculous
laws we're basically making outlaws
really wealthy we just don't have that
money to waste anymore I think
decriminalizing and are legalizing
marijuana should be the first step
people are really hesitant to change
laws related to drugs because they feel
like they'll be encouraging crime I
think if people sort of d link those two
then we can move forward I think it's
fear I think it's fear and lack of
information and lack of education and
that's what's so great about the drug
policy Alliance is that its main mission
is to educate the masses and I think the
idea is to take care of the
overzealousness of the government and I
think those people should be treated not
as criminals prisons are big business
and that there are far too many people
that are in there to try to fill our
prisons with tens of thousands of people
for you know simple things like small
quantity possession and things like that
it's just absolutely insane yeah I
missed the whole cocaine but I don't
judge those people
Frank they think that we're treated like
children in this country we're going to
legalize a few things don't you think I
think the wind is at at our backs to
make some some substantial changes in
these drug laws decriminalization of
possession personal use grow growing for
personal use that kind of thing could
make a world of difference we can
certainly start with marijuana how about
that